the Joe Rogan experience and do you
think one of the motivating factors
would be the price of health care that
the argument would be part of our issue
with health care and the an incredible
amount of money that needs to be spent
on hospital as I hospitalizing peaceful
people and treating them with diseases
we could eliminate that oh yeah that's a
huge part of it at the moment when you
talk to any you know any people any
electric representatives any way of a
very persuasion about the ating question
than the immediate knee jerk reaction is
always Oh God we definitely don't want
to fix that how would we pay the pension
right because they obviously they know
if the economy's Cupid it's delicious
yeah and so that's I think and the fact
if you're not going to be able to get
away with that kind of thinking anymore
it's going to have to be a case of
redesigning a large number of really big
parts of the economy from the ground up
well especially places like where you
live in England or used where you're
from rather in England where they have
socialized medicine the enormous cost of
that would be decreased radically we're
healthier it's it's got nothing to do
with privately socialized medicine in
medicine yeah in the US and the UK and
everywhere else the overwhelming
majority of medical expenditure is on
the health problems of the elderly which
will go away now of course the medicine
that makes those problems go away is not
going to be free I mean to produce and
to deliver so but prevention is always
better than cure but that actually is
only a minority of the economic benefits
the real economic benefit comes from the
indirect cost first of all the fact that
the kids are the elderly are going to be
more productive because they're not
having to spend time looking after their
sick parents and you know relate things
like that but also the huge thing that
the algorithm cells are still going to
be able bodied and therefore in a
position to you know continue to
contribute wealth to society right now
that doesn't necessarily mean anything
to do with the retirement age this comes
back to another aspect of the
interaction between emerging
technologies so of course we've got
automation coming I don't work
anymore but lots of people do right
we're making huge progress in artificial
intelligence and most people even
conservative commentators say that most
of the jobs that exists today are going
to be gone 20 years from now said
machines will be doing things perfectly
well so you know we're going to be
completely unable to continue this
system of a an economy based on full
employment you know last time this
happened with the Industrial Revolution
we got away with it by inventing an
entire new sector you know the service
sector that replaced all the jobs that
people didn't have anymore in
manufacturing and agriculture you know
it's not gonna happen this time it's not
gonna happen you know how many people do
you need in the entertainment industry
you know we've got you come on it's a so
you know we're going to have a different
well of course people are already
thinking about that with things like you
know universal basic income yes which is
an extraordinarily blunt instrument it's
just a starting point but you know that
kind of thing is going to have to going
to happen I can totally imagine a
situation in which you know 30 40 years
from now work is something like national
service used to be yeah yeah well you
yep well yeah when you're young and
insignificant you do a bit of a few
years of actual work and then yeah but
that means that the whole concept of
pensions it's ridiculous to think about
that so we've got a gas policymakers out
of that mindset and to get them to think
in more global terms about the health
benefits and the benefits the quality of
life of everybody and so on it is funny
that work or the concept of work is sort
of inexorably connected to society to
the point where you think you have to
work but you know meanwhile people lived
for hundreds of thousands of years
without even the concept of that you
know I got a place where you go where
they give you gold coins yeah I mean of
course you do have to have something
that something something that fulfills
something to do that you find fulfilling
that's the argument for universal basic
income right the argument against it is
human nature that people need to be
motivated and they need something to
sort of guide them towards excellence
yeah my take is the other thing that
needs a better education which of course
is something that we could spend
that we save from not having to yeah
GLaDOS half full guy well I don't know
anybody well educated who gets bored you
know yeah I agree with you or anybody
who's been exposed to interesting things
right there are so many things in this
world I mean if I had I would love to
live five different lives concurrently I
would love to I would I would I would
love to they don't have to be concurrent
they climb just dive into they like I
would love to live different lives cuz
there's so many different things that I
would have loved to pursue well you
can't let them concurrently can get one
right but let's try to make you live
them sequentially instead yeah well
seeking which will be fun
I'm it would be really interesting to
take up a whole new career at seventy
you know and so this three to five year
timeline what what makes you think that
three to five years from now is when all
this stuff will take place well it's
subjective it's based on aggregating a
whole bunch of different areas of
research but of course I'm fairly
well-informed about where is that
currently isn't how rapidly it's moving
in a variety of different areas I'm so
just you know just I'm putting all that
together in my head and I'm saying how
soon are we going to be able to take
mice that normally live let's say two
and a half years and do nothing
whatsoever to them until they are
one-half and get them to on average live
to four instead of two and a half right
now if you can and of course those extra
years would be healthy years because we
would be rejuvenating the mice right so
I believe that that would be sufficient
any of it that's actually a little bit
conservative I think a less dramatic
breakthrough them that might be enough
to switch most of my colleagues over
that get them over the fence but I think
that would definitely be enough and I
think that that is close
[Applause]